اسال الله السلامه لجميع المواطنين في
ولايه ديار بكاريه الاثنين كان قوه
الزلزال سبعه فاصله سبعه ومن ثم زلزال اخر
بقوه
7.6 على مقياس ريختر
العديد من الولايات
وابنها ولايه ديار بكر ايضا كما تعلمون ان
الذاكره الجمهوريه التركيه هي
مليئه
بالزلازل ولكن الزلزال الاكثر
تعلقا في اذاننا هو
زلزال عام
1999 ايضا كان
قبله زلزال اخر لكن هذا الزلزال هو من
اكبر
الزلازل الذي وصل الى هذا الحجم والقوى
الكبيره منذ اربعينيات القرن الماضي
العديد من الولايات تضررت منها
مراديه والعديد من الولايات الاخرى ولكن
لا يمكن ان نقوم باجراء مقارنه بين هذا
الزلزال والزلزل السابقه
الهزه الارتداديه ايضا كانت كبيره جدا
واصبحت دولتنا في المرتبه الاولى من حيث
الازات الارتداديه لهذين الزلزلين
الكبيرين
قمنا بزياره وجوله الى جميع الولايات
المتضرره وعالمنا عن قرب وعن كسب بان
جمهوريه تركيا
الان داخل افا وكارثه كبيره جدا جميع
العلماء في العالم يتحدثون عن نفس المشاعر
المشاعر ويتحدثون
العلوم العلميه في هذا الزلزال
والجميع يتحدثون عن قوه هذا
الزلزال قوه مدمره كبيره على طول كبير
وعلى عرض كبير اكثر من 14
مليون مواطن تضرروا بالزلزالين الكبيرين
بالاضافه الى
الهزات الارتداديه بذلنا قصارى جهودنا من
اجل
الوصول الى جميع المناطق المتضرره اعتقد
بان العدد الاجمالي للمتضررين والمنكوبين
قرابه 20 مليون مواطن ممن يعيشون في
المناطق المنكوبه والمناطق المحيطه بها
العديد من التخريبات
وهذا سواء في
طرق شكك الحديد والطرق المعبده الدوليه
بالاضافه الى العديد من الامور الاخرى
الزلزالين الكبيرين كان مدمرين عدد
مباني التي
قدمت تقدر بمئات الالاف من المباني حجم
الخسائر هي كبيره جدا لا يمكن لهذه
المنازل ان تستخدم مره اخرى
واحد
وعشرون الف ضحيه وثلاثه واربعين
[موسيقى]
تعدد الضحايا بالاضافه الى عدد
الناجين قرابه 89
الف في ولايه ديار بكر قرابه
320 بنايه لم تعد
استخدم
اكثر من
جارحا تم ايصالهم في هذه الولايه
الى المستشفيات اسال الله الرحمه والمغفره
لجميع الضحايا هذا الزلزال واسال الصبر
والسلوانه لجميع عائلاتهم وشفاء العاجل
لجميع الجرحى عمليات الانقاذ
وبحث تم الانتهاء منها في العديد من المدن
وما زالت الاعمال على قدم وساك في ولايه
اخرى في قرمان
[موسيقى]
الولايات الثلاثه هي الاكثر متضررا بذل
قصار جودنا من اجل ايصال فرق الانقاص
والمساعدات والاغافات كانت هنالك الزيارات
الى هذه الولايات وقمنا باصدارها
التعليمات اللازمه
المجمل اقول كيف كنا الى جانب مواطنين في
هذه
الافات والسيول والحرائق ولا الطبيعيه
سنبذل قصارى جهدنا من اجل الوصول الى هذه
ولايات فقط انتظر منكم
عاما واحدا
الاعمار واعاده الابناء
سنقوم بانهاء خلال عام واحدا فقط
نجحتنا كما كانت موجوده في الولايات
السابقه وفي الافات الطبيعيه السابقه ان
شاء الله سنكون ناجحين في ولايه ديار بكر
وفي الولايات الاخرى بذلنا قصار جودنا من
وجع من اجل وضع جميع الامكانيات والطاقات
العائده 100 مليار ليره تركيه
خصصناها من وزاره الخزينه التركيه نسال
منكم الوثوق الكامل لم لم ندع ولن ندع اي
مواطنا متضررا في هذا الزلزال
الحكومه منظمات المجتمع المدني وجميع
امكانياته وطاقتي هذه الدوله هي تحت الظرف
المواطنين الان
160 الف عامل في البحث
وانقاذ من داخل تركيا ومن خارج الان
يعملون ليلا ونهارا بالاضافه الى جميع
الاجراءات سواء
بتقديم
الغذاء والوجبات الساخنه
وتقديم الاسعافات الاوليه في المستشفيات
والمراكز الصحيه
يعمل جميع عاملين بشكل كبير ولكن اقول مع
الاسف لربما بعض الاحزاب السياسيه او بعض
السياسيين او بعض منظمات المجتمع المدني
الذين
يفتقدون او يفقدون ادنى سويات الاخلاق الى
الان ما زالوا يريدون الصيد في المياه
العكره اعتقد باننا الان
في وقت مطلوب منا التعاون
والتضامن التضامن فقط الصيد في المياه
العكره
نجاحتنا هي تتحدث عن نفسها في جميع الافات
الطبيعيه التي تعرضنا لها
الحكومه تملك الامكانيات والطاقات اللازمه
من اجل اعاده الاعمار واعاده الحياه الى
ما كانت عليها جميع القوات المسلحه
التركيه والمعدات العائده لها
عشرات الالاف من اليات الان تعمل ليلا
ونهارا
وقمت بتوجيه جميع الامكانيات والطاقات
العائده الى الوزارات
في الحكومه من اجل تقديم الخدمه
يعملون ليلا ونهارا على الرغم من جميع
الظروف الاصابه ولكن دون ان يناموا ولو
للحظه واحده
اشكر جميع العاملين
ان هنالك من يريد
ان يجعل او يصيد في المياه العكره ولكن
اقول بان العاملين لا يريدون الشهره ولا
يريدون اي شيء منا سوى تقديم الخدمه
اشكرهم فردا فردا كما اشكر جميع الدول
الصديقه والشقيقه على ما قاموا به بتقديم
المساعدات والاغافات الى الجمهوريه
التركيه
اخواتي اخوتي الاعزاء على الرغم من كبر
وقوتي هذه الافه ولكن نحن دائما نثق
بقوتنا وامكانياتنا الموجوده
اسالكم ان تثقوا
تتفائلوا بنا
الان جميع الولايات التي تعرضت
للزلزال مجهزه
بمخيمات وبدانا ايضا
ببناء
المنازل
ببناء المنازل المؤقته كما قامت العديد من
الفنادق والمباني
العامه باستضافه
جميع المنكوبين اريد الاعلان
لاول مره في ولايه ديار بكر اقول
باننا جميع وحدات الوحدات السكنيه
الطلابيه ستكون تحت خدمته المواطنين ومن
ابتداء من اليوم وحتى نهايه هذا الفصل
سيكون التعليم عن بعد اغلاق الجامعات
وستخدم
جميع المباني العائده الى الجامعات
والوحدات السكنيه
الطلابيه تحت التصرف في جميع المنكوبين في
الولايات العشره قمت بزياره الوحدات
السكنيه الطلابيه والمباني الجامعيه
وكان هنالك لقاء لي مع الذين يقيمون في
وحدات السكنيه هم فرحون ومسرورون
بهذه
الاستضافه ايضا تكون الوحدات السكنيه
الطلابيه في ولايه ديار بكر ايضا قادره
على استيعاب المنتظرين
والمنكوبين العديد من
الخطاه قد وضعناها من اجل نقلي المتضررين
والمنكوبين الى المباني العامه بالاضافه
الى مباني المخيمات كما سنقوم
بتقديم الخدمه الكامله سواء للنقل او دفع
ايجارات البيوت والمنازل لكل من يريد
الاقامه في البيوت وفي المنازل سواء في
نفس الولايه او الول
اخرى هنالك العديد من الاجراءات والخدمات
التي سنقوم بتقديمها من اجل نقل المواطنين
والمنكوبين الى الولايات الاخرى
ايضا كما
مع الاسف خلال هذه الايام الصعبه هنالك
بعض الاشخاص الذين لا يملكون ادنى سويات
الانسانيه او الضمير
الانساني الذين يحاولون استغلال هذه
الظروف والصيت في المياه العكره نحن قمنا
باصدار
حالتي الطوارئ في الولايات العشره
الكبرى وتم الموافقه عليها من مجلس الامه
تركيا والان ادخلت الى حيز الحيز العملي
والتنفيذ ليعلم الجميع
باننا لن نتنازل قيد شعره للحفاظ وحمايه
جميع
المواطنين نسالوا من جميع المواطنين الثقه
والتفاؤل الكامل بالامكانيات والطاقات
الموجوده لنا خلال الف عام
تاريخه شعبنا مليء بالنجاحات والانتصارات
والتغلب على جميع الظروف الصعبه لربما
هنالك بعض الحملات الذين كانوا يصفوننا
باننا لن نقوم بعد كل حادث او افا نتعرض
لها اقول للجميع باننا حكومه قمنا باعطاء
الوعود وقمنا بتنفيذها وعدا طلوع الاخر
ان شاء الله
سنكون مع بعضنا البعض بعد عام في ايام
سعيده
وفرحه واعاده الاعمار والبناء سيكون
العنوان الابرز
اسال الله ان يجعلها اخر الاحزان وان
يوفقنا في تقديم الخدمه الى مواطنين